Bon bah, j'vais y aller moi.
Attends, faut qu'on fasse une photo d'abord !
Ouais, si tu veux.
Je vais bientôt être tonton !
Dans deux semaines !
Ah m*rde...
J'ai plus de place...
Bah on la fait la prochaine fois parce que là,
vraiment, je suis très en retard...
Ok ok vas-y vas-y... Et bonjour au Papa hein !
Ouais bah là il est en séminaire pendant deux semaines.
Je t'ai pas dit, trop bien.
Ah bah courage !
Tu m'appelles hein !  Bisous !
Faut que j'fasse de la place moi...
OH PUTAIN ! #catastrophe !
Les gars, on a un problème !
Je crois que Damien il va supprimer l'un d'entre nous !
Mais Twitter, reste tranquille !
Il va supprimer quelques photos, c'est tout !
Tu t'affoles pour rien wesh !
Alors ça m'étonnerait...
J'ai plein de photos de son ex
Mais Damien veut en supprimer aucune, donc...
Twitter a raison
Il y a l'un d'entre vous qui va dégager
Je vous l'avais dit ou pas ?!
#Itoldyou !
*musique entraînante*
Hé c'est quoi cette musique ?
Ah c'est moi ! J'ai mis une petite musique !
J'me suis dit... P'tite ambiance !
Bon !  Débrouillez-vous entre vous, les vieux
Moi, il m'utilise tout le temps et il risque pas
de me supprimer
Il vient pour chill 5 minutes et il scroll pendant
des heures, tu connais !
Ouais enfin... Il scroll des vidéos d'ados de 14 ans qui font du playback
Donc s'il te supprimait, ce serait pas plus mal
WHAT !?
De la bouche du mec qui propose que des vidéos
"Je mange bleu pendant 24 heures !"
et "J'essaye des produits Wish" ?
J'ferais moins mon malin quand même
Ouais enfin il regarde pas que ça...
Sa dernière vidéo dans son historique c'est quoi ?
"DÉGUSTATION GIGA TACOS EN COUPLE"
Ah ça m'intéresse ça !
Pas YouTube...
Écoutez, on arrête les gamineries !
On reste calme, ok ?
On va supprimer Twitter !
Quoi ?
Non non non non non !
On fait pas ça !  Pas du tout, non non !
Moi je suis super utile pour suivre l'actu, par exemple
*toutes les applis rigolent parce que c'est faux*
Pas à nous, Twitter, on le sait tous...
Tu sers juste à suivre des mecs qui se croient drôles et à retweeter des concours, ça va
T'as même pas de preuves qu'il y a des gagnants à ces concours !
Voilà, tu te fais pigeonner c'est tout
Alors déjà, un jour on va peut-être gagner une PS4 et là
tout le monde va bien fermer sa gu*ule !
Et toi, Instagram, je te ferais dire que...
À part suivre des c*ls tu sers à rien, donc euh... #pervers !
Quoi ? Alors pas du tout, rien à voir
Ah ouais ?  C'est qui Emily Ratajkowski ?
Une comédienne
Cite-moi un des ses films
Damien : Pouf...
*changement de musique*
Alors moi je suis d'accord avec Twitter
On peut supprimer Instagram !
Je fais déjà les photos, ça fait doublon !
Je fais les stories d'ailleurs aussi hein donc euh...
*rire et moquerie générale*
Il fait les stories !
T'es un ouf dans ta tête ou quoi ?
Personne ne les regarde tes stories wesh !
Les stories c'est moi, tout le monde le sait !
Pardon Snapchat ?
C'est moi, les vraies stories !
#idée !
Et si on supprimait Horloge ?
Non, non, moi... moi on peut pas
Ah m*rde, on peut pas supprimer l'horloge...
Bah oui !  Mais c'est comme Messages là !
Regardez-le avec sa tête de c*n...
Moi ?
On peut pas le supprimer alors qu'il sert à rien
depuis que je suis là, p*tain
Hop hop hop hop WhatsApp !
Y a aussi mon fils Messenger qui envoie des messages hein donc prend pas trop la grosse tête !
Il a dit quoi Papa ?
Non mais t'inquiète pas Messenger !
Laisse parler les grands
Mais wesh ? Les messages c'est moi !
Les vrais messages, les messages avec les potes
y a des délires et tout tu vois ?
Supprimez-le l'autre gamin là il sert à rien !
*Messenger pleure*
Messenger mes c*uilles là !
Comment tu parles de mon fils !?
JE SUIS PAS UN GAMIN !!
WOWOWOH !!!
#onsecalme !
Bats les c*uilles...
Nous, on est en page 1 ! On a rien à craindre !
Si il doit supprimer une application, c'est forcément une
application en page 2
Twitter a raison, en page 2 y a genre... Uber !
Damien il est fauché, il l'utilise jamais !
Autant le supprimer !
Je tiens à rappeler que je suis quand même très pratique
Lorsque Damien rentre totalement bourré à 4h du matin et qu'il y a plus de métro
Si vous cherchez des dépenses inutiles...
Tournez-vous plutôt vers Tinder !
Hein !  Quoi ?
Vous voulez me supprimer ?
Mais bien sûr !
Il a pris l'abonnement Tinder Premium, les boosts,
le compte-gold, la totale, il match que dalle!
Abonnement gold ?  Attendez c'est quoi ça ?
C'est quoi, j'ai vu ça passer...
Me supprimez pas, sivouplé...
P*TAIN, VOUS AVEZ VU COMBIEN ÇA COÛTE !?!
Il a surtout du mal à oublier son ex...
Exactement...
*musique triste*
Il a même créé un compte anonyme pour continuer à la suivre sur Instagram...
Et il se morfond sur lui-même, sans sortir de chez lui...
Et là...
PAF !
J'interviens avec des sushis !
Attends-tends-tends-tends !
Le restaurant japonais il est juste en face de l'appart !
Il peut se déplacer quand même !
Deliveroo tu sers à rien, on le supprime !
Mais tu sais pas ce que c'est que d'être déprimé, Google Maps...
Tiens regarde, un burger, ça va te faire plaisir !
Ah bah, merci ! J'avais faim en plus..
"En ce moment, profitez de -20% sur le cassoulet Gradou !"
Qu'est ce qu'on entend là ?
Tais-toi, tais-toi...
"Umm, le cassoulet Gradou !"
Non, mais c'est parce qu'il a pas pris l'abonnement
payant, c'est pour ça en fait...
Allez...
Excusez-moi mais y a des applications je sais pas ce que c'est !
Qu'est ce que c'est la CAF ?
Alors, moi si on me supprime, on est à la rue....clairement
Ah non pas la...  Non, pas la CAF...!
Ouais d'ailleurs !
Petite parenthèse mais on doit 5 euros à Thomas, hein !
Les bons comptes font les bons amis
Ouais faudrait qu'on reste pote avec lui !
On squatte son compte quand même...
Et allez...
Ah non mais pour l'argent vous inquiétez pas !
Damien il a trouvé un business de fou
On revend ses vêtements d'occasion sur Vinted !
Attends, on gagne de l'argent avec ça ?
Ouais !
Enfin surtout les sous-vêtements, il en a vendu pas mal..
Euh... sales !
Parce que les... les vendeurs demandaient ça...
Ah le coup des caleçons, c'était bizarre ça...!
Attendez les gars !
Mais c'est qui ce mec en page 2 là ?
Workout ?
C'est pour qu'il fasse son sport de manière quotidienne !
T'es sûr qu'il t'as déjà ouvert ?
Parce que moi je vois ses photos tous les jours hein
Et je peux te dire qu'il gagne de la graisse, pas du muscle
Effectivement, il m'a jamais ouvert
Mais... euh s'il me supprime, il peut dire adieu à son futur
corps de rêve !
Ouais, le corps de rêve, moi je... je veux bien !
Ça m'aiderai à matcher
*en espagnol*
Mais attendez...
Pourquoi on te supprimerait pas toi Facebook, au fait ?
Non non non non !
*en espagnol*
Bah j'peux supprimer Facebook en fait...
*musique de suspense*
Non non non non non, attendez ! Nous on est très important avec mon fils Messenger, on garde contact avec les gens !
Ouais, avec les tontons, les tatas, c'est tout wesh !
Et les anniversaires !
Rah, les anniversaires ouais c'est vrai...
Les anniversaires, qui c'est qui les retient pour vous ?
Eh bah c'est Bibi !
Eh tu viens de dire "C'est Bibi" wesh ?
Mais t'as quel âge ?!
Ouais surtout que retenir les anniversaires,
je peux le faire, hein !  C'est pas la mort
Wesh on supprime Facebook ! On s'en bat les c*uilles, le mec est vieux comme le monde, allez ça dégage !
Allez...
#adieu !
NON NON NON NON NON NON !!
ME SUPPRIMEZ PAS S'IL VOUS PLAIT !
LES ÉVÉNEMENTS ! VOILA !
JE SAIS FAIRE LES ÉVÉNEMENTS !
Allez je supprime...
AH ! NON !
ME SUPPRIMEZ PAS S'IL VOUS PLAIT !
PAS LA CROIX !
PAS LA CROIX S'IL VOUS PLAIT !
*notification messages*
Ah !  Nouveau message !
C'est sa sœur qui dit :
"J'ai perdu les eaux. Je suis seule. Je vais à l’hôpital.
Est-ce que tu peux venir me chercher ?"
Oh p*tain...
*oh p*tain général*
Musique dramatique !
*enclenchement de la musique*
Ok tout le monde, on reste déter !
Damien il a besoin de nous wesh !
Lucie vient de m'envoyer sa localisation !
Euh, tiens Google Maps !
Ok, je chope le chemin le plus rapide pour la rejoindre !
Oh m*rde, y a une ligne de métro qui est en travaux !
C'est pas grave !
On va lui trouver un vélo à proximité, il va faire du sport !
C'est très bien pour lui !
Y a un vélo à côté !
S'il part maintenant, il peut arriver au point de rendez-vous à 16h52, voir 53 pour récupérer sa sœur
Ok, une fois arrivé je commande un chauffeur et hop!
Direction l'hôpital !
Ça coûte combien une course Uber euh ?
On s'en bat les c*uilles combien ça coûte !
ALLEZ ON FONCE !
Je contacte les cousins, les cousines, les frères, les sœurs !
Facebook, t'as qu'à contacter les parents, les grands-parents, les tontons, les tatas !
On fait ça ! Messenger, c'est à nous !
Ouais !
Et moi j'envoie une petite story à un pote !
Je-vais-être-tonton
#famille #fierté !
Zéro like.
Bon...
Faut attendre un peu
C'est lent.
Merci d'avoir été là.
Non, c'est normal.
Je suis trop content pour toi !
Regarde comme il est mignon !
Mais oui il est trop chou...
Faut qu'il fasse sa première photo absolument
D'accord
Vous... voulez que je la prenne
comme ça vous êtes tous les 3 dessus ?
Oui oui
Oui, oui pardon oui
Merci !
Hop
Ah, y'a plus de place
Ah m*rde... euh, une petite seconde hein...
Oui.
*plainte et panique générale des applis*
Et ça recommence et c'est parti...
P*tain m*rde m*rde m*rde on est dans la m*rde encore
*musique triste et nostalgique*
Vous inquiétez pas, on va faire ce qu'il devait faire depuis très longtemps
Supprimer les photos de son ex !
Yes !
Et bah voilà !
Espace libre !
#soulagement hein !
Monsieur, vous regardez pas l'objectif !
Oui pardon.
Le stress
Hop, voilà !
Merci !
Vous êtes beaux tous les trois
Vous... Vous aussi !
Je dis n'importe quoi, pardon
Dis-lui que t'es mon frère quand même...
Oui ! Je suis son... frère. C'est... mon neveu.